since the fetchweathertask is in the
fragment the menu option to trigger that
task should be inside the fragment -
that means we should create a new menu
layout for the fragment and we'll call
it forecast fragment XML the file will
live within the menu folder under the
resources directory inside that file
we'll declare the new menu option for
refresh and give it this menu item ID
we'll also need to define a string label
for this word refresh we're taking this
one step at a time so just make the menu
XML file change in this exercise if you
compile and run the app will be no
visible change it won't show up on the
device yet because we haven't inflated
the menu item inflating it will be in
the coding test after this see how the
menu made that XML is implemented as an
example for an additional hint see the
menu training guide below when you're
done you can click on this box here